hoy me levanté con muchas ganas de
seguir con esos problemas de ese arte y
de hecho vamos en el problema número 11
que por cierto dice que tenemos un
triángulo abc que es este triángulo que
estoy poniendo aquí es el triángulo abc
y que cada ángulo del triángulo abc
tiene la misma medida que algún ángulo
del triángulo x 10 z y no nos dan el
triángulo xz pero no nos podemos
imaginar porque nosotros sabemos que
tienen cada ángulo igual entonces son
triángulos semejantes vamos a poner aquí
un triángulo que parezca que se parezca
a este vamos a suponer que es este de
aquí vamos a poner que este es el
triángulo semejante al a éste y por
cierto tienen como vértices x
y se está muy bien y por cierto nos da
las medidas del triángulo abc dice que
este lado mide 3 este lado
mide 4 y este lado grande mide 6
perfecto y después nos dice el problema
si la medida de uno de los lados del
triángulo x receta es 24 cuál es el
posible perímetro del triángulo x 10 z
orale qué divertido este problema va a
tener tres soluciones es decir tres
respuestas correctas lo que aumenta tu
posibilidad de que lo tengas bien vamos
a suponer en primer lugar que no sé
alguno de estos lados tiene que ser 24
así que voy a suponer que es este como
tenemos tres posibles soluciones
entonces voy a ver los tres posibles
casos y bueno como tú sabes cuando
tenemos dos triángulos cuyos ángulos son
los mismos de una manera inmediata
sabemos que son triángulos semejantes
son triángulos similares o semejantes lo
que quiere decir que se ven igual pero
que tienen una
la diferente y si has visto el vídeo que
hice sobre triángulos semejantes
seguramente vas a tener más noción sobre
esto que por cierto este vídeo está en
la lista de geometría entonces si estos
dos triángulos son semejantes la
proporción entre sus lados debe de ser
la misma la proporción entre sus lados
debe de ser la misma y bueno como
tenemos el dato de que uno de esos lados
y vamos a suponer que es este lado es 24
en primer lugar esta es la posible
solución entonces si suponemos que el
lado correspondiente a este triángulo es
este lado que mide 3 es decir estos dos
lados son correspondientes y ojo no
sabemos si este es el correspondiente
por eso estamos viendo el primer caso
suponiendo que este sea el lado que
corresponda en este triángulo bueno si
éste lo fuera y recordando que los
triángulos similares deben de tener
razones iguales entre sus lados esto
quiere decir que 3 es a 4 como 24 es
y bueno sí tres para llegar a 24 lo
multiplicamos por 8 entonces dicho de
otra manera 4 para llegar a este número
habrá que multiplicarlo por la misma
razón porque son triángulos semejantes y
por lo tanto 4 por 8 es 32 este lado
debería de medir 32 unidades esto si
queremos conservar la proporción y bueno
si multiplicamos éste por 80 24 este
otro por 8 y nos da 32 entonces 6 por 8
nos va a dar 48 y aquí ya tenemos un
triángulo que tiene los mismos ángulos y
es similar porque sus lados son
proporcionales y si este fuera el caso
es decir recuerda que estamos en el
primer caso entonces cuánto valdría su
perímetro
bueno pues su perímetro va al día 24 48
más 32 y esto es 10 14 y llevamos 13
610 104 unidades esto en un primer caso
ahora qué te parece si pensamos que este
es el lado que corresponde a este lado
esta sería otra forma de resolver este
mismo problema estamos en el segundo
caso y si este lado fuera a este lado
entonces 3 este lado tendría que ser
alguno de estos y bueno a 4 lo
multiplicamos por 6 para llegar a 24
entonces a 3 lo tendríamos que
multiplicar por 6 para llegar a este
lado 3 por 6 18 este es el segundo caso
ya 6 lo voy a multiplicar también por 6
para llegar a este lado 6 por 6 36
entonces en un segundo caso en una
segunda respuesta correcta
tendríamos que tomarnos la suma de estos
3 es decir 36 más 24 más 18 y cuántos
esto si yo lo sumo el perímetro de este
triángulo va a ser 10 18 llevamos 1
13 14 y 2 son 6 778 pero también hay un
tercer caso podríamos decir que este
lado sea correspondiente a este otro
lado de este triángulo que ya se está y
si esto fuera cierto a 6 lo
multiplicamos por cuatro para llegar a
ser 24 entonces 3 lo tendremos que
multiplicar por 4 lo cual me daría 12 ya
4 lo tendremos que multiplicar por 4 lo
cual me daría 16 y entonces en este
tercer caso el perímetro de este
triángulo del triángulo xz serían 16 más
24 más 12 lo cual es 10 12 llevamos una
24 552 y aquí están tus tres posibles
soluciones las cuales las tres son
correctas del perímetro de este
triángulo recordando que tienen los
mismos ángulos y por lo tanto son
triángulos similares así que vamos a
pasar al siguiente problema vamos a
poner la pantalla negro y ahora si
problema número
12 dice la suma de cinco enteros
consecutivos es 1000 cuál es el mayor de
estos enteros consecutivos así que voy a
decir que el mayor de estos enteros
consecutivos se llama x y bueno si este
es el mayor de estos enteros
consecutivos el que está antes de x es x
menos 1 y el que está antes de x menos 1
es x menos 2 y el que está antes es x
menos 3 y el que está antes es x menos 4
aquí ya tengo 5 enteros y los 5 son
consecutivos donde x es el más grande
ojo
este es un tip que te doy si te piden el
más grande empieza por equis y de ahí ve
restando 1 x menos 1 x 2 x menos 3 x
menos 4 si en su dado caso me pidieran
el entero más pequeño entonces empezaría
también en x pero en lugar de restar
sumarían x + 1 x + 2 x + 3 x 4 así es
más fácil de resolver estos problemas y
bueno las
de estos cuantos la suma de estos vamos
a hacerlo yo aquí tengo ekis ekis ekis
ekis ekis lo cual es 5x y después tengo
menos 1 - 2 - 3 - 4 entonces 36 10 la
suma de esto es 5x menos 10 y esto dice
el problema que es igual a mil esto es
igual a 1000 y esto ya está muy fácil
tenemos una ecuación de primer grado
entonces para despejar a x lo que voy a
hacer es sumar 10 de ambos lados de la
ecuación más 10 + 10 de tal manera que
estos dos se van a ir y de este lado me
queda mil diez mil diez 5x es igual a
mil diez y ahora voy a dividir todo
entre cinco esta parte entre cinco esta
parte entre cinco estos dos se van y
ahora si el valor de x es igual a 1010
en 35 lo cual es 205
205 110 es 210 es 2 es 202 x es igual a
202 y este es el más grande de estos
enteros consecutivos así que ya está
vamos a pasar al problema número 13
déjame borrar esto y ponemos aquí el
problema número 13 que dice y dice
tenemos una gráfica gtx no mira para no
perder más tiempo déjame ver si puedo
copiar y pegar la gráfica la tengo por
acá y a ver si puedo aquí está perfecto
aquí está muy gráfica que está en este
problema la cual dice que es muy gráfica
de ye igual que de x y es esta que tengo
aquí estas elegidas x esto es el eje de
las 10 y bueno el problema te dice que
si hdx déjame ponerlo por aquí si hd x
es igual
de 2x
2 si la función h la defino de esta
manera entonces lo que me pregunta el
problema es cuánto vale hd 1 y bueno
para sacar hd 1 lo que hay que hacer es
sustituir a x por 1 y vamos a ver que
llegamos es decir h de uno es igual a g
de dos por uno porque x vale uno estamos
sustituyendo a x por uno más dos que es
lo mismo que g de dos por uno dos más
dos
pero si nosotros nos fijamos aquí en la
gráfica esa es la función y es igual a x
sube baja y g de 2 está justo aquí este
de aquí es g de dos entonces cuanto al
eje de 2 pues g de 2 vale 0 está justo
en el eje de las x por lo tanto esto es
lo mismo que 0 + 2 y esto es 2 un
problema de funciones que por cierto
tengo varias secciones sobre funciones
deberías de checar los vídeos sobre
funciones de khan academy y bueno creo
que todavía me da tiempo de hacer un
cuarto problema así que para hacer este
último problema déjame borrar todo el
pizarrón y ahora sí voy a poner algún
nuevo por acá y vamos a hacer el
problema número 14 que dice exactamente
cuatro actores tienen que actuar en
cuatro partes de una obra de teatro
entonces vamos a notar eso
cuatro actores y tengo cuatro partes de
una obra de teatro cuatro partes me
dicen si cada uno de estos actores tiene
que actuar en una parte de la obra de
teatro es decir voy a utilizar los
cuatro actores y ninguno de ellos puede
aparecer en dos partes distintas de esta
obra de teatro y ninguno de ellos puede
repetir entonces de cuántas maneras
pueden aparecer los cuatro actores en
las cuatro partes de la obra de teatro
es decir supongamos que esta es la parte
uno está aquí es la parte dos este de
aquí es la parte 3 y está aquí es la
parte 4 si tengo cuatro partes de una
obra de teatro de cuántas maneras puedo
acomodar a estos cuatro actores así que
para la primera parte tienes disponibles
cuatro actores entonces imagínate que te
gusta mucho un cierto actor o una cierta
actriz y lo decides poner aquí entonces
vamos a poner al 1er
entonces de los cuatro actores que
tienes aquí tienes en la primera parte
cuatro posibles actores que poner en
esta primera parte sin embargo ninguno
de los actores se puede repetir por lo
tanto cuando ves la parte 2
aquí ya pusiste a uno de estos cuatro
tienes cuatro posibles actores y ya
elegiste a uno sin embargo para esta
parte 2 solamente tienes tres posibles
actores porque ya elegiste uno para la
parte 1 entonces en esta parte 2 vas a
tener tres posibles actores y en la
parte 3 pues ya elegiste uno para la
parte 1 de elegiste uno para la parte 2
de estos cuatro se queda uno de estos
tres se queda uno y para la parte
derecha solamente tienes dos posibles
actores entonces para la parte 3 ya
solamente tienes dos posibles actores
con los cuales vas a elegir a uno para
que actúe o que tenga el papel número 3
y bueno ya para la parte 4 de la obra el
papel número 4 se le va a quedar el
último actor que te sobre como ninguno
puede repetir aquí ya elegiste a uno de
los cuatro aquí a uno de los tres aquí a
uno de los dos y por lo tanto
solamente te queda un actor y bueno si
yo quiero ver todas las posibles
combinaciones que tengo de estos cuatro
actores pues habrá que multiplicar esto
y me queda 4 por 3 12 por 2 24 por 1 24
24 posibles formas y ya está aquí ya
tenemos la respuesta de este problema
que por cierto esto debería de estar en
nuestros problemas y en nuestros vídeos
de combinaciones y de probabilidad así
que estaría muy bien que lo revisara un
poco pero bueno espero que te haya
quedado bastante claro y nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo